and Nicole is walking out right now I
think he's getting ready to take a seat
he is about to take a seat we'll get him
miked up
congratulations champ
congrats
way to go Joker nice job nice job uh can
you hear us yet through the mics you
halfway there no not really oh
we'll get you there
you might need this
you're gonna need that
um this is this is Serbia wow this is
what's happening tonight in Serbia's
family and friends
look at the people Wow Wow on the
streets my bad my bad that's all for you
boss that's everybody
having having grown up there
oh yeah that's cute not as good
all right it's beautiful that's great
you know in Italy it's four o'clock
maybe even in five plus eight
six
yeah yeah 6 30 in the morning
they pulled an all-nighter for you yes
you know nah
when you go home you always don't uh
kind of let the people that you know I
have a lot of guys and number people
that I grown with and it's I'm coming
from a small City and everybody little
knows me and I'm always worried what
they're gonna say when I go home you
know and I hope they think they're gonna
say good things about me right now
because there's a lot of good things
they probably will I think a lot of
them are 30 in the morning you were so
calm when the when the buzzer sounded
you went over and said congratulations
to the heat but it the moment didn't
seem surprising to you what was going
through your head uh you know my mom
teach me one thing don't get high and
lose don't get it down and don't get
high in the men's don't get down and
lose and I really respect Miami Heat uh
I think they're a great team
maybe in some ice they uh they exceed
the expectation but not in my mind
my mind I think they're really really
intelligent team really teams that uh
know what what they are doing
defensively in office and I think that's
why that's why that's why they're in the
finals and I'm just happy that uh uh we
won the game
Nicola talk to us a little bit about you
know your relationship with Coach Malone
it seems like it's such a unique and
special relationship and such a
different one than than what we normally
see in the NBA with coaching players to
be honest even in the United States no
or yes
no when they when they brought me a a
MVP to uh title in Serbia uh I told the
the whole time it was a family a Conkey
actually Josh and coach and I told I'm
gonna be honest with you guys and uh
you're honesty is something that I
thrive and uh I was always honest to
them I think that's why that's why coach
and might have a good relationship I
always tell what they think it's
sometimes it's good sometimes it's bad
you know but uh honesty relationship uh
good communication
trust in believing each other I think
that's why that's why
we came here
it seems like you you and your family
have adopted coach Malone after after
the after the game your brothers are
throwing them up in the air like a
little baby I mean look look at that
yes but here coach was a coach was in my
in my hometown couple times uh we were
drinking couple times so you know just a
couple in my hometown
uh he's a great competitor uh uh that's
why he said it's it's not the first one
we we were hungry we won the second one
and uh that's actually what even one one
sentence to describe him that's that's
the center to describe him well I'm
trying to describe you again because
your game is nothing like I've ever seen
from the center position before as far
as your completeness and one thing that
really stands out to me is your passing
and I can't remember if it was Jamal or
if it was Aaron that said you're a point
guard at the center position how did you
develop that
special passing ability that you have
that makes everybody better I think one
guy can only can win it maybe a game of
course but the whole thing he cannot win
it I think you need a teammates and when
you're passing and you're trusting each
other and when you're passing it
in the game I think the whole team wants
to play it it's better to play than in
passing you know everybody touch the
ball even refill they are contributing
to the game you know so
I think it was passing something that is
always in my game uh and I just like it
you know what what part of the Season
that you really felt you guys have had
success you've had individual success
well what part of the Season where you
felt we really can witness we can win
the whole thing this year and the
additions that you guys it's a great
picture yeah I was listening the whole
thing yes
I was listening there it is that is a
great picture
too I was listening to finish what part
of the city uh to be honest in the
beginning
yes we had a if you're if you look at
the schedule of the last four games we
had a really bad we lost Detroit we lost
to Houston we lost
at home somebody I think Chicago was
struggling in in the Beatles in our home
uh but like I said you need to fail you
need to you need to you need to be bad
you need to be you need to lose and then
you're gonna figure out how to win
um
it's it's a team that wins and I really
truly believe in that what are the next
week or two look like for you now you
get a parade coming up here on Thursday
yes how soon till you're back inside for
the Sundays I have my horse racing
I was going to get to that the horse
maybe I don't know how we're gonna
arrive Thursday parade Friday maybe
would you make it I don't know maybe
maybe you can have enough time to
squeeze it in I'm gonna ask Josh to give
me a give me a give me a plane oh I
think I think yeah he'll definitely let
you get the team playing you deserve
that you deserve a little more than that
I did it on TV I'm gonna finish my uh I
put him under the pressure yes I did
Nicole but I don't feel bad at all
I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap up by telling
you something that I know you don't care
about but it's worth repeating you're
one of 10 players in NBA history now
with two regular season MVPs and a
Finals MVP two players ten ten okay so
the League's been around a while how
many years seventy one five six seven I
don't know where what do we have 76.
pretty good pretty good not bad not bad
not bad not bad he says bad not bad not
bad
it's a small Club it's a small Club
thank you guys congratulations on your
uh your entry in the club and the
championship Club as well great job
thank you get that playing finals MVP
congratulations best player in the world
good luck in the uh the horse racing
getting back to sambore the parade
they're playing all of it
[Music]